plusieurs centaines de manifestants se
sont rassemblés hier soir d'un côté ceux
venus défendre le droit à l'avortement
d'un autre se réunit pour le dénoncer
aux pieds de la cour suprême une
amérique divisés selon le site
d'information politico la cour suprême
s'apprête à annuler un arrêt historique
reconnaissons depuis près d'un
demi-siècle droit à l'avortement le
média politico qui sape et sur une fuite
inédite document s'est procuré l'avant
projet d'une décision rédigée par un
juge conservateur porté par le juge
samuel alito il permettrait à chaque
état d'interdire ou d'autoriser
l'avortement la moitié d'entre eux
notamment dans le centre et le sud du
pays pourrait bientôt le bannir de leur
territoire ce serait vraiment une
décision radicale et chaque décision
basée sur la notion de vie privée serait
remise en question
juriste et politologues estiment que si
cette décision est confirmée des droits
comme l'homosexualité le mariage pour
tous ou même la contraception pourrait
être menacée pour les socialistes ça va
être encore pire puisque ils vont
quelque part jeté à la mer l'héritage
mitterrand au lobe bombay mais c'est
leur survie ils ont fait ce choix si on
veut être crédible dans la démarche il
faut qu'on porte un projet politique en
commun et il faut que chacune des
formations politiques n'est qu'un seul
candidat dans chacune des
circonscriptions j'ai le sentiment - oui
linge oz soit en train de bouger vous
trouvez qu'il dit la même chose sur un
certain nombre de questions vous trouvez
qu'il dit la même chose sur les
socialistes huilée il est en train de
changer tout le monde est en train de
changer on n'a qu'un objectif c'est
réussir pas pour nous pas pour nous
réussir pour une chose changer la vie
des gens et quand je rentre tous les
jours dans ces pièces de discussions et
de négociations
je le fais pas pour moi je le fais pas
pour mon parti je le fais pas pour moi
vous fassions la france je l' ai vu et
je le fais en écho à la dcc script si je
le fais pour les françaises et les
français il ya encore pas mal de prendre
tension donc on espère qu'ils seront
levés le plus tôt possible
vous en doutez des points ce sont
toujours les mêmes des points
programmatiques la répartition des
circonscriptions voilà ça prend ça prend
du temps je sais que vous êtes
impatients ce que vous demandez des
points qui sont des points durs de la
discussion par exemple cette question on
les a beaucoup été on a beaucoup parlé
ces derniers jours dans les médias sur
la fameuse désobéissance aux traités
européens mais vous savez et d'émettre
martichoux c'est plus souvent de
l'incompréhension en réalité que de
véritables points de blocage à mon avis
j'ai du mal à croire que tous les
socialistes je pense
historique et je pense que si cet accord
électoraliste et non pas programmatique
et signé ce soir vous allez avoir une
scission parti socialiste cet accord il
peut pas être discutée en petit nombre
les militants c'est un changement lignes
stratégiques majeures et les militants
doivent être consultés comment
peuvent-ils signé la fin de tout ce pour
quoi ils se sont battus moi je crois que
cet accord n'ira pas jusqu'au bout parce
que je pense qu'il y a suffisamment
d'hommes et de femmes de conscience qui
ne l'accepterons pas partir de là où
nous engager dans un processus où à
l'assemblée nationale et demain et bien
mais sauront dans une gauche mélenchon
ni zay moi je ne crois pas que ce soit
utile pour les français et que ce soit
surtout utile pour la gauche vous êtes
en train d'expliquer que jean luc
mélenchon en disant qu'il veut être
premier ministre d'emmanuel macron berne
un peu les français oui bien sûr je
pense qu'il est là la béquille du
système et je pense surtout que c'est
cohérent parce que jean luc mélenchon il
a fait lire emmanuel macron il aida et
l'a soutenu emmanuel macron il a offert
ses voix emmanuel macron le
rassemblement national ne voulait pas
d'accord le rassemblement national veut
la mort de reconquête voilà c'est un
fait on a là un parti qui s'appelle
reconquête et où tous les ténors tous
les cadres du parti ne veulent pas
s'engager dans la bataille législative
en tout cas même le chef de la famille
eric zemmour et mais comment on peut
hésiter quand on regarde la situation du
pays s'il hésite c'est parce qu'il sait
que lui-même ne pourra ni se qualifier
au second tour ni espérer être député à
l'assemblée nationale